so the question is what happens on
Saturday's Main Event so if Strickland
can dictate the pace he's going to blow
DDP out of the water if he can dictate
the pace just like he did with Izzy just
like he's done before and avoid the big
shot which I think he's learned from the
Alex Pier fight not to play that game if
he can control the pace if he can
continue to put DDP on his back foot
he's going to blow the doors off DDP I
do have Shan Strickland winning this
fight I have him win this fight I think
he can TKO him in the fourth round Shan
Strickland's been in much bigger fights
so all signs to me Point towards Shan
Strickland unless he gets caught which
can definitely happen but my money would
be on Shan Strickland I think we show
him a little more respect I think just
going ah I he had a bad night
Strickland's not that good that ain't
going to work for me the kid's damn good